the 2020 election is nearly two years
away but in political terms that's right
around the corner potential presidential
candidates are stepping out of the
shadows and launching an exploratory
committee for president we'll be right
here at hua Deluca Plaza to make a big
announcement about my 2020 plans so I'm
pleased to announce on the view that I'm
not ready to make mine but let's be real
these politicians aren't just starting
to get serious now they've been working
methodically behind the scenes for
months and even years to bring their
likely campaigns to life let's take a
look at the presidential candidate to-do
list everything a White House hopeful
typically gets done before officially
announcing their candidacy first and
foremost presidential candidates have to
start fundraising and establishing donor
networks long before their official
start date for example senator Elizabeth
Warren and former secretary Julian
Castro have launched exploratory
committees we need a strong vision for
the future this allows them to raise and
spend money to test the waters that
includes traveling to meet voters and
donors and conducting polling other
politicians like Los Angeles Mayor Eric
Garcetti and former Colorado Governor
John Hickenlooper have set up political
action committees or PACs PACs allow
people to raise money without the same
restrictions that govern campaign
donations and the funds can be used on
things like ads and events that help
build national support
the money can also be donated to other
politicians who can later help with a
presidential bid but the use of PACs
could backfire since they've been
shunned by many in the Democratic
Party's progressive base and some
prospective candidates have even bowed
not to use them become I don't take PAC
PAC money not a dime things are a little
different for billionaires who might
sell fun it is a very heady thing when
people yell run run run anybody that
thinks it is and should see a shrink but
most candidates will need to raise some
serious cash in 2016 candidates and
outside groups spent nearly two and a
half billion dollars on the race to the
White House
that's according to election watchdog
open secrets those planning to run also
need to attract talented staffers and
that can be tough when there's a large
pool of potential candidates senator
Bernie Sanders recently held a Vermont
summit through his Sanders Institute
that brought together staffers and
supporters from 2016 and politicians
like Cory Booker Jeff Merkley and
Kirsten Gillibrand have reportedly
already reached out to potential hires
in key primary States politicians are
also making the rounds with both media
tours and road trips to key states like
Iowa where the state's early caucus can
make or break a candidate that includes
former Vice President Joe Biden senator
Cory Booker Congressman John Delaney and
governor Steve Bullock and splashy book
tours like those launched by Senators
Kamala Harris and Elizabeth Warren also
raised a candidate's profile the tours
helped politicians network with key
supporters and build name recognition to
essential ingredients for a presidential
campaign and finally there's the
political platform candidates need to be
clear about where they stand on the
issues before they launch a campaign
sitting representatives and senators
might introduce legislation to establish
their positions or sit on key committees
this is about the closest I'll probably
ever have in my life to an I am
Spartacus moment and many looking to
enter the race have already launched
websites and published videos that
explain what they're fighting for and
while both parties seem to focus on
fighting I'm focusing on the future in
total at least two dozen Democrats are
thinking about running and after they
battle each other for the nomination one
will ultimately face President Trump
[Music]